I'm Phil de paola tailor 16 times world
dog's champion sorry I'm a dolphin
what's the key to success dedication and
doing a lot of practice love staying in
not going out with your mates its
dedication dedication dedication if
you've got to set your targets in life
so if you work in the shop and you want
to be the manager if you want to be the
manager you want to run them you know
want to be the managing director so I'm
always setting me Charlie so if I want
12 world titles and 130 I've got 16 I
want 17 so eat something they're
motivating forget about the money think
about cars and allergies your first
thing I wanted to do is have no Morgan
we count your screen no other mortgage
other mortgage that you can start up
I've nothing no mortgage so I mean mum
and dad bought me off but if you want
something you save up in your biker and
that's what I do you know so if I want
something I'll go pay cash for I don't
want to slow down never mind I'm still
18 years old but you got it you've got
to be realistic now and you've got to
think yourself right you know going bed
at one o'clock in the morning again
avatar for six doesn't work anymore from
there you know I've got a lot of money
in the bank
you see shouldn't have a lot of money
one should be out there any money for
you because I'm old-fashioned
I'm all right up till well I'm a
multi-millionaire and people look you
know monetary wise people want to be
written this will cause you do I have to
laugh actually I have to laugh at some
of the nicknames I was driving me and
Bubba driving somewhere the other day
and it will spend another Phil Taylor
he's got Phil the plumber tailing I
thought this is really lovely